[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité quand la tournée
du pain touche à sa fin et au TV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord et du Courrier
Picard nous racontera l'angoisse d'un
village privé de pain depuis quelques
jours en cause des coûts de l'énergie
trop élevés pour la boulangerie locale
eux aussi sont en danger les Restos du
Coeur peine à répondre à la demande
alimentaire par tout en France le nombre
de bénéficiaires augmente en même temps
que les coûts d'activité de
l'association comme nous le montrerons
TBO et huit Mont-Blanc dans quelques
instants des raisins chaussées sur des
skis TL7 dans la loi nous fera découvrir
cette drôle de méthode déployée dans une
vigne pour le moins pentu vous le verrez
et puis en fin de journal télé Grenoble
nous proposera des images
exceptionnelles des falaises du Vercors
où était organisés il y a quelques jours
un rendez-vous de Highline une activité
sportive ou l'équilibre côtoie un
panorama extraordinaire
voilà mais on débute donc ce journal je
vous le disais dans les titres avec
l'inquiétude qui accompagne la fin de la
tournée du pain dans un village de la
Somme à Cambron la baguette n'est plus
livrée aux habitants depuis la fermeture
de la boulangerie la plus proche du
village en cause des factures
d'électricité trop importante et des
conséquences évidemment sur la vie
quotidienne des habitants les précisions
avec ce sujet de Jérôme ou Bron pour
jouer au TV la chaîne de la Voix du Nord
et du Courrier Picard
voilà maman ton pain d'aujourd'hui bien
frais deux baguettes qui Isabelle
apportent à sa mère Ghislaine voilà qui
pourrait devenir un rituel car depuis
jeudi dernier à Cambron il n'y a plus de
boulanger pour assurer la livraison de
pain c'est désagréable quand même
surtout pour les personnes âgées les
personnes qui sont un peu seul ou qui
n'ont pas de bon voisinage ou autre sont
obligés de mettre je pense du pain au
congélateur ou se passer de pain en 40
ans cette commune près d'Abbeville n'a
jamais manqué de pain après la fermeture
de sa boulangerie en 2004 un
établissement d'une commune voisine
avait accepté d'assurer la livraison de
pain il y a quelques jours ce dernier
annonçait au maire mettre la clé sous la
porte noyée par des factures d'énergie
en hausse
téléphone monsieur le meurt
débrouillez-vous un petit peu pour nous
trouver une boulangerie c'est vraiment
c'est important d'avoir au moins du pain
peut-être pas tous les jours mais un
jour sur deux il y a comme sur Cambron
il y a pas que des jeunes qui ont une
voiture il y a c'est une population
vieillissante Claude est l'ancien
boulanger du village s'il lui arrive
d'assurer bien volontiers la livraison
de pain de certains habitants c'est que
pour lui la boulangerie est une affaire
de lien les gens bon ben ils se
côtoyaient en chercher leurs pains ils
se parlait
se donner des nouvelles du village s'il
y avait quelqu'un de malade ou au pire
un décès
on apprenait ça la boulangerie selon la
mairie une boulangerie de
Saint-Valery-sur-Somme pourrait bien
reprendre la livraison de pain à Cambron
dès la semaine prochaine
voilà et vous le savez il n'y a pas que
les petits commerces qui peinent à faire
face les associations sont elles aussi
menacées financièrement parmi les plus
emblématiques d'entre elles les restos
du cœur ont annoncé récemment être
obligé de réduire le champ de leurs
actions
os du nombre de bénéficiaires inflation
et baisse des dons impactent l'activité
de l'association créé en 1985 par
Coluche la preuve à l'Orient avec ce
reportage de Karine chevrolier pour TBO
la chaîne du couple
telegramme
ça fait deux points dans un point
supplémentaire parce qu'on n'a pas du
tout de crudités et pendant plus de
légumes faut que ça tienne jusqu'à midi
en cette matinée de distribution de
denrées alimentaires l'antenne
l'orientèse des Restos du cœur ne des
emplit pas oui on a plus de monde et pas
forcément les mêmes personnes on a de
très jeunes et puis des gens qui
viennent d'arriver et puis aussi des
très âgés qui ont du mal à boucler le
fnoir 15% c'est le nombre de repas
supplémentaires distribués par rapport à
septembre dernier près de 900 familles
orientaises franchissent désormais les
portes du resto du coeur mais
l'association doit faire face à un autre
problème mon sentiment c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup moins de produits qui arrivent
on a beaucoup moins de viande déjà et
beaucoup moins de ramassent conséquence
les restos du cœur prévoit de
restreindre le nombre de leurs
bénéficiaires pour la campagne hivernale
les barèmes d'été plus restrictifs
devraient être appliqués si les restos
du cœur sont plus en capacité à
distribuer comme ils le font aujourd'hui
ça veut dire qu'on va sortir des gens
qui sont en précarité du service qu'on
peut leur apporter risque aussi d'avoir
une démotivation de bénévoles parce que
quand vous êtes face à des gens et que
vous devez leur dire non en permanence
ou limiter ce qu'on pouvait faire avant
ça risque de démotiver bénévoles même si
la Bretagne reste moins touchée que
d'autres régions plus de 7 millions de
repas devraient être servis cette année
soit un million de plus qu'en 2022
[Musique]
davantage de repas distribués pour les
restos du cœur en Savoie également
là-bas aussi la situation de
l'association est inquiétante et
préoccupe bénéficiaires comme bénévole
images et propos recueillies par
Sébastien Germain journaliste pour la
chaîne 8 Mont-Blanc regarde les mesures
annoncées elles ne sont pas rigolotes et
puis parce que on va servir moins de
personnes et qu'on servira moins aux
personnes qu'on continuera à accueillir
donc effectivement beaucoup de tristesse
mais je suis pas la seule à penser ça on
est tous très triste de ces annonces
vous savez quand on augmente la facture
d'électricité de 10 ou 15% 20 euros
d'augmentation sur le facteur
d'électricité pour quelqu'un qui a déjà
pas de quoi finir le mois c'est
catastrophique avec 20 euros ces
personnes là ben se nourrissent donc
voilà c'est pour ça qu'on a autant de
personnes qui viennent nous voir et des
personnes qui avant s'en sortait à peu
près bon ils étaient pas très riches
mais elles arrivent à s'en sortir
maintenant elles nous disent avec
l'augmentation des factures d'énergie je
n'y arrive plus
voilà et sachez que si vous souhaitez
aider l'action des Restos du Coeur vous
pouvez faire un don en vous rendant sur
le site internet resto du coeur.org et
puis également celui de la Banque
alimentaire française ces banques
alimentaires point org voilà les verres
en font-ils trop c'est la question que
se pose le magazine Le Point en Une de
son édition spéciale consacrée à la
ville de Lyon cette semaine
l'abdomadaire adresse un bilan à
mi-mandat de la municipalité écologiste
à la tête de cette ville Grégory Doucet
le maire de Lyon répond notamment aux
questions du journal Le Point qui
consacre aussi une édition à la deuxième
ville de France Marseille et sans
surprise vous le verrez la question de
la sécurité et scruter de préparer
hebdomadaire comme celle du tourisme
d'ailleurs et du logement comme vous le
voyez sur ces images ces deux éditions
spéciales sont à retrouver bien sûr chez
vos marchands de journaux et vous pouvez
vous vous déplacer facilement à pied
dans votre ville la question peut
paraître surprenante elle est pourtant
bien d'actualité trottinette vélo
scooter voiture ou encore bus il est
parfois bien difficile de marcher en
ville selon une récente étude parmi les
territoires de France les moins piétons
compatibles on retrouve sans surprise
Paris et sa région toutes les
explications avec ce sujet de Mélanie
Faure pour la nouvelle chaîne
francilienne 20 minutes TV regardez
véhicule trottinette vélo et piéton à
Paris les usagers cohabitent au
quotidien une mobilité plurielle mais
pas simple surtout pour les plus
vulnérables traversés c'est plus
compliqué il y a des fou furieux il y a
des il y a des virus arrête même pas il
te voit arriver le feu il est vert et ça
reste même pas c'est plus simple à
corbeille franchement ça fait peur quand
même même tout à l'heure là le monsieur
il s'est arrêté et pourtant c'était vert
je vais pas me faire des ennemis mais
les trottinettes les vélos tout ça là ça
dérange beaucoup quand même un baromètre
dévoilé par le collectif place au
piétons révèle que Paris fait partie des
villes les marchable en 2023 avec une
note de 7 sur 20 au globale en bas du
tableau Aubervilliers Bois-le-Roi ou
encore Maison Alfort et
Saint-Maur-des-Fossés parmi les communes
les mieux notées en Île-de-France on
retrouve la ville de Sceaux
Asnières-sur-Seine ou encore ici les
moulinons on peut remarquer que plus les
métropoles sont importantes plus il est
difficile du marché ou plus les piétons
considèrent qu'il est difficile du
marché des notes de 11 par exemple sont
d'excellentes notes pour les métropoles
qui n'est pas le cas pour des communes
plus petit nombreux usages dit davantage
de conflits d'usage et problème plus
complexe à régler mais volonté de les
régler et de les régler dans le sens où
ce sont les piétons qui doivent être les
usagers prioritaires de la ville des
efforts dont Paris à redoubler en
publiant en juillet dernier son tout
premier code de la rue
voilà c'est la fin de l'été toujours le
même constat à l'heure de la cueillette
dans les vergers le manque de
saisonniers se fait criant pour récolter
les fruits qui seront ensuite vendus en
commerce ou sur les marchés alors pour
pallier le manque de main d'oeuvre les
producteurs peuvent compter heureusement
sur la volonté de réfugiés et demandeurs
d'asile un contrat légal gagnant-gagnant
comme a pu le constater près du Mans
Anthony Python pour elle MTV
depuis fin août un lit prend un bus tous
les matins au moins à 6h10 pour
embaucher ici à 8h Ali est arrivé en
France il y a trois ans son travail pour
les deux prochains mois que hier de
pommes c'est important qui est ce
travail et c'est nous on est dormi dans
la rue ah ouais plutôt j'espère un jour
je restais un bon mécanicien et aussi
comme lui ils sont 53 à faire la route
depuis Le Mans pour un travail payé au
smic des réfugiés mais aussi des
demandeurs d'asile qui bénéficient d'une
dérogation de la préfecture pour
travailler pour le producteur qui peine
à recruter c'est une main d'oeuvre
nécessaire au plus fort de la saison il
peut employer jusqu'à 150 personnes on a
toujours eu besoin de faire venir des
gens de d'ailleurs ça nous ça nous aide
quand même beaucoup pour arriver à
récolter les fruits dans de bonnes
conditions et à la bonne maturité je
vois pas de souci à faire à faire
travailler qui que ce soit à partir du
moment où il la bonne volonté qu'il a
envie de travailler quoi c'est
l'association Celta Damoun qui prend en
charge le transport grâce aux aides
financières de l'État et du département
de la Sarthe elle nous a mis non pas
pris les horribles bateaux en Libye en
pensant au RSA donc oui c'est c'est
aussi le moyen de retrouver une forme de
dignité que travailler parce que bon
nombre d'entre eux merci la France pour
tout ce qu'elle leur a donné en premier
lieu la paix l'accès aux soins enfin le
fait de pouvoir reconstruire une vie
mais ça demande une énergie incroyable
de reconstruire une vie le travail est
assuré jusqu'à la fin de la cueillette
fin octobre voir début novembre
des pommiers aux vignes dans ce journal
restons en extérieur pour découvrir une
surprenante technique de vendanges dans
la Loire à l'aide de ski oui vous allez
bien entendu des skis pour transporter
le raisin une astuce quand les pentes se
font raides comme nous le montre Anthony
verpillon pour la chaîne TL7 dans la loi
donc regardez la mandat vernale c'est
c'est de monter quand vous allez faire
au vététiste
lors de la fête du bouteille en et on
n'est pas sur le plus vendu et faire les
vendanges chez Jean-Marie et Philippe
Vial ça se mérite après avoir avalé les
33% de la première pente c'est que tu as
45% que les vendangeurs doivent évoluer
ce matin et les conseils du viticulteur
sont les bienvenus le mieux pour monter
c'est de mettre les pieds en canard
comme ça vous montez plus facilement
aussitôt dit aussitôt fait et c'est
forcément pour les vendangeurs que la
tâche s'annonce la plus ardue vous
imaginez ici avec un porteur de haute 40
kg sur le dos donc sur la pente donc
faut tenir au sol et l'idée a été de
mettre la
la chose des skis voilà c'est pas le bon
dangereux
on avait des problèmes d'assurance sinon
l'idée et donc venue aux deux frères
après une longue réflexion de la malice
et un petit coup de main ça fait bosser
notre matière grise et notre bureau
d'études à nous et on a trouvé cette
idée de ce qui
on appelle ça des béninski en fait c'est
des bennes rouges
qu'on retrouve partout qu'on a clipsé
dans une dans un cadre en bois avec des
spatules de ski coupées à la longueur
monte avec la moto qu'on sert toute
l'année pour travailler dans les vignes
on a un neveu qui est
en Savoie et qui connaît du monde et du
coup il nous a trouvé l'esquisse sans
souci Antoine lui fait les vendanges
pour la première fois et après un
comparatif avec la cueillette sur un
terrain plat ces derniers jours le jeune
homme préfère être ici en pleine pente
debout sur une parcelle normale
accroupie au bout d'un moment le dos il
supporte plus les jambes et tout donc là
on a un choc roupie je descends comme ça
hop et je ramasse c'est petit à petit et
je continue jusqu'à la fin et à l'avenir
Philippe aimerait même pourquoi pas
faire inscrire cette épreuve aux Jeux
Olympiques c'est du skin descente on va
dire oh là là ce qui descend tout schuss
le monde vit qui colle décidément plein
de surprises avec cette autre initiative
venue cette fois-ci d'Occitanie un
producteur de muscat à immerger ses
bouteilles pendant 10 mois au milieu des
huîtres résultat un vin iodé et étonnant
qui a eu le droit aux honneurs d'un chef
étoilé les détails d'Anthony Coutin
pourvie Occitanie
au milieu des huîtres ces bouteilles de
muscade de Fitou ont reposé toute
l'année englouti au fond du lac de
Leucate blotti contre ses coquillages et
bercé par l'onde des vagues on a émergé
ces bouteilles il y a pratiquement 10
mois et donc sur les temps de Leucate
donc sur les parcs à huîtres c'était un
des pochons à huîtres et l'idée
maintenant c'est amener une évolution et
on va avoir ce côté lyonnais on va avoir
ce côté finesse aussi qui va apparaître
de retour au vignoble Laurent découvre
enfin le résultat de ces 10 mois
d'immersion si la robe est similaire le
nez du vin immergé est plus développé
avec un parfum d'écorce d'orange
particulièrement marqué on est bien sur
un vin blanc de macération on est bien
sur un cépage le muscat mais ce qui
m'amuse aussi c'est que ces pages
amènent des notes d'agrumes ce vin a
suffisamment cohabité avec les huîtres
pour que leur union soit consommée le
mariage d'humain et du vin sera ici
sublimé par la cuisine du chef étoilé
catalan Paul boreille on a fait des
petites billes de concombre qu'on va
ajouter sur le sur l'huître
l'expérimentation elle se fait déjà un
par la par une expérimentation sur le
sur un échange entre artisan humain on a
un éleveur d'huître agriculteur un
vigneron on a un cuisinier du vin et des
huîtres anobli par la gastronomie et
voici une triple alliance de toutes
élégance
il pourrait être considéré comme un
enquêteur des champs Laurence un Dizier
au père dans les grands espaces de sa
région depuis 10 ans à l'aide de ses
outils favoris des détecteurs de métaux
une activité qu'il pratique pour le
loisir mais qui n'est pas sans intérêt
pour les sols et leurs propriétaires
puisqu'il permet de dépolluer les
terrains Livia Buchler et Denis le Ken
journaliste pour vos TV l'ont suivi le
temps d'une sortie dans une parcelle
agricole regardez ce reportage
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est les boutons et des petites bacs
quand même on en trouve ça c'est tout
des vagues mais sont sans intérêt quoi
c'est de la balle de pacotille et c'est
majoritairement dans les champs que
Laurent trouve ses objets qu'il conserve
dans cette boîte depuis bientôt 10 ans
et ses débuts dans la détection de
métaux chaque semaine pendant plusieurs
heures il parcourt les terrains
agricoles à la recherche de trouvailles
bien sûr mais ce n'est pas le seul
objectif et un aspect très important
donc des polluent le plomb la lube à
tous les métaux qui sont dans les champs
en fait surtout du plomb il y en a
beaucoup et de l'alu on crie sur les 20
cm on enlève quasiment tout ce qu'il y a
dans les 20 cm
un loisir bon pour l'environnement mais
qui doit être pratiqué dans les règles
ça c'est la poubelle
[Musique]
en boule et qui a été acheté là c'est
juste de l'aluminium on a le droit
d'aller partout sauf les sites
archéologiques tout ce qui est sites
archéologie et lieu de combat en fait
mais uniquement avec l'autorisation du
propriétaire quant au trouvaille tout
objet datant d'avant 1875 ou appartenant
aux deux conflits mondiaux doit être
déclaré en mairie et ne peut pas être
gardé pour le reste la décision revient
au propriétaire du champ qui
majoritairement laisse le butin au
détectoriste lors de notre tournage
hormis des métaux dédiés au recyclage
Laurent a fait une autre trouvaille ça
c'est mieux
donc juste après guerre chaque année en
moyenne cette enquêteur des champs
extrait environ une tonne de ferraille
130 kg de cuivre et 100 kg de plomb et
pour que les solv Vosgiens continuent
d'être dépollués de cette manière une
antenne vosgienne de la Fédération
devrait voir le jour d'ici peu
allez ouvrons à présent une page sport
dans ce journal avec d'abord cette belle
histoire en pleine Coupe du monde de
rugby de jeunes joueuses d'un club de
Haute-Garonne ont été sélectionnés pour
assurer le rôle de ramasseuse de bal
lors du match Japon Samoa qui se tiendra
jeudi prochain à Toulouse une fierté
forcément pour ses joueuses passionnés
d'ovalies propos et images recaltées par
Manon van Overbeck pour la Dépêche du
Midi
j'ai reçu le message et qu'on a été
prise j'étais vraiment hyper contente
parce que je m'y attendais pas et
que je m'étais dit que c'était
impossible il y allait avoir trop de
clubs c'est pas encore développer enfin
c'est pas encore beaucoup développé le
rugby féminin mais ça commence de plus
en plus et on est content d'en faire
partie ça permet de montrer à tout le
monde que les filles elles peuvent aussi
faire du rugby et que c'est presque
commun maintenant enfin ça va devenir
comment en tout cas
voilà bravo à elle et bon match donc
pour jeudi prochain moi physique que le
rugby met tout aussi populaire surtout
auprès des plus jeunes le eSport ne
cesse de se développer partout dans le
monde les stars des jeux vidéo ont à
peine la majorité c'est le cas vous
allez voir de Cyprien en Gironde à tout
juste 18 ans il est l'un des meilleurs
joueurs au monde du fortnite un talent
qui lui permet de voyager dans le monde
entier ils vont brancher de tv7/7 du
groupe sud-ouest c'est glissé dans sa
chambre le temps d'un entraînement
rencontre
au rythme du clavier les yeux rivés sur
son écran Cyprien du Monteil est en
pleine entraînement sa passion ce
célèbre jeu en ligne une immense
bataille où le dernier survivant
l'emporte sorti en 2017 son succès est
immédiat et comme beaucoup de jeunes de
son âge l'adolescent tombe sous le
charme et comme tous les jeunes j'ai
joué de façon traditionnelle ou juste
j'aime le jeu et avec les tournois qui
sont qui sont arrivés en ligne et bah
simplement j'ai joué de façon amateur et
quand j'y ai performé et tout simplement
je me suis muscler un nom et c'est comme
ça que ça a commencé c'est comme ça que
Cyprien est devenu au fil du temps
x-wise
[Musique]
l'un des 20 meilleurs joueurs européens
suivi par plus de cent mille personnes
sur les réseaux et a tout juste 18 ans
le jeune homme s'entraîne jusqu'à 10
heures par jour assis sur sa chaise je
sais que c'est pas hyper dingue
ça permet de simplement premièrement de
respirer et surtout d'avoir en sorte une
activité physique parce que je reste
tout le temps assis quoi même prendre
l'air sans proactivité physique c'est
important mais
oui en soi c'est hyper important et ne
vous fiez pas son apparence pour
compenser ce mode de vie sédentaire le
joueur suit un programme sportif adapté
salle de musculation
ostéopathe alimentation son entourage
est notamment sa mère managieuse
surveille sa forme de très près un
joueur professionnel capable d'enchaîner
les récompenses durant les tournois
Suède Danemark Arabie Saoudite en tout
Cyprien a déjà gagné près de 250 000
euros mais pas question de le dépenser
l'objectif est d'investir dans
l'immobilier
la montagne Pelée au patrimoine mondial
de l'UNESCO la nouvelle émerveille les
Pierrotins qui louent ses avantages
vraiment très fiers de voir que la
montagne Pelée les pythons et le Nord
Caraïbes de façon générale
pourront pourront être reconnu connu de
Parlement entier ça fait plaisir pendant
ces que la montagne Pelée tout ce qui
s'est passé effectivement en 1902 au
marché couvert cette vendeuse voit déjà
le potentiel de cette distinction nous
aurons plus de clients oui en ce moment
regarde le marché c'est nous n'avons pas
de clients mais quand même si la matinée
qu'on devient patrimoine de l'Unesco
alors le monde entier vont venir visiter
la fierté peut se lire sur les visages
mais le travail ne fait que commencer à
sur le maire de Saint-Pierre il nous
faut faire en sorte de de prouver que
nous sommes prêts à entretenir ce bien à
le valoriser notamment par la gestion
des déchets des des choses qui sont dans
le paysage du bien et il va falloir
qu'on traite ça le Martiniquais sont
appelés la responsabilité le site de
l'aileron c'est même vu investi de
nouveaux marchands la montagne Pelée
patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO est un
titre qu'il faudra maintenant honorer
selon le maire du morner rouge nous
avons un travail à faire avec les tas
pour que enfin l'aménagement se réalise
parce que ils vous disent que nous
sommes en zone rouge si on regarde bien
nous toutes les communes autour de la
montagne Pelée nous sommes en nous ça
veut dire qu'on ne fait rien on a
construit pas on ne fait rien on reste
là on attend que les choses se fassent
sur le ben non on va se battre pour
faire annuler les freins qui interdisent
la progression de l'aménagement qui est
attendu depuis plus de 10 ans la
Martinique à l'Unesco c'est également le
patrimoine de Laguiole ronde ainsi que
le titre réserve de biosphère
voilà de splendide images de la montagne
Pelée et de son environnement qui nous
conduisent dans le Vercors maintenant ou
se tenait il y a quelques jours un
rassemblement consacré à la pratique du
Highline cette activité impressionnante
consiste à parcourir une distance au
dessus du vide sur une sangle pour
l'occasion 22 lignes étaient installées
dans un décor exceptionnel entre nature
et équilibre suspendu sujet de Mirco
péchie pour Télé Grenoble
perché à 1600 mètres d'altitude sur les
falaises du plateau d'éramés dans le
Vercors des passionnés de Highline
participent à la dixième édition de la
marmotte Highline project cette
discipline unique amène les participants
à s'équiper d'un baudrier et un marché
sur un câble tendu au-dessus d'une
impressionnant de verticalité c'est un
festival à la base de Highline pure
Highline c'est l'activité de
funambulisme en groupe montagne en gros
hauteur et ça a commencé il y a 10 ans
dans ce spot là-haut ou MHP l'évolution
elle est incroyable c'est ça grandit
avec le nombre des highlines qui sont
installés là-haut avec le nombre de
participants qui vient de je pense pour
cette édition à la 18 pays différents
180 personnes sont venues expérimenter
le légendaire en placement du MHP ou 22
Highline ont été mises en place 30 100
ou 200 mètres chaque ligne variant
longueur et en sensations les
participants ressentent toujours une
montée d'adrénaline je suis tombé
d'abord sur la slackline au sol entre
les arbres
comme ça et après c'était l'occasion de
faire un week-end en montagne à tester
cette activité ça m'a vraiment fait peur
mais finalement c'était quand même
attrayant il y avait un peu ce truc de
dire ah ouais je me lève la sensation à
l'effort une occasion en fait de
découvrir la montagne sous un autre
angle et au milieu de vie aussi on a
vraiment un panorama exceptionnel les
bénévoles sont là pour garantir la
sécurité de tous en surveillant les
installations et le matériel utilisé par
les participants ils ont reçu une
formation pour intervenir en cas de
problème dans le but de prévenir tout
risque lié au syndrome du harnais quand
on est inconscient le poids mort du
corps fait qu'on est dans une position
qui coupe la circulation sanguine très
rapidement donc faut sortir la personne
de cette de cette position et la ramener
au bord le plus rapidement possible le
festival offre une opportunité unique de
pratiquer cette discipline en communauté
c'est se rassemblement qui fait du MHP
un événement incontournable pour les
passionnés de la highline
voilà une pratique époustouflante faite
de concentration et de silence aussi le
silence justement touriste et visiteur
sont invités à le garder lors de leur
balade à canoë sur le delta du fangou
encore un espace doté d'une riche et
incroyable biodiversité et donc vous
découvrez quelques images à l'écran
grâce à nos partenaires de télépaser sur
place de bien belles images naturelles
pour terminer ce journal voilà c'est la
fin de cette édition merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis on se retrouve très
vite pour une nouvelle édition du Grand
JT des territoires au revoir
[Musique]